unprecedented and dangerous move in
Georgia Stacey Abrams came out earlier
today and while she claimed she probably
doesn't have a path for victory in this
race she's still falling short of making
a concession to Brian camp further she
says she'll file a federal lawsuit to
challenge quote gross mismanagement of
the Georgia electoral process hmm
so let me get this straight you don't
like how the election is playing out so
you threaten legal action and at one
point call for an entirely new election
after browbeating then candidate trump
back in 2016 over whether or not he
would accept the results of the
presidential election the Democrats have
now made this constant challenge posture
their new normal no one likes to lose I
don't but this is all getting a little
bit ridiculous here with reaction is
someone who represented the great state
of Georgia as Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich and Newt first question well
the Abrams can't feel this emboldened do
you think if Democratic leaders like
they had Hillary Clinton down there you
had Cory Booker sherrod Brown was there
egging them on basically saying if she
doesn't win the election was stolen
let's start with that you have a whole
series of Democrats who've just said
bluntly if Arkana doesn't win they stole
the election they'll have no proof of it
but they have a whole model now whether
it's yelling racist or whatever it is
where if they smear you enough this is
the Cavanaugh model repeated over and
over again so Georgia they want to set
up stacey abrams so she'll be the person
who had the elections stolen from her so
for the next four years she can run for
governor as the person who should have
been governor except it was stolen from
her of course since she's black it must
have been an act of racism and therefore
the whole thing compounds this is a game
they're playing if you look at Florida
which has a similar problem we now know
thanks to USA Today the Democrats
actually were methodically planning to
cheat
when the election after it became so
close and actually were printing up
materials that were designed just to
steal the election they only backed down
because they got caught but we're seeing
in both Florida and Georgia a very
similar pattern if you don't let the
Democrat winning then you're cheating
and it's been stolen because you're not
allowed to win they're supposed to win
the Georgia code on when you can contest
the result of an election is very clear
section 21 - 2 5 2 - as a result of a
primary or election may be contested on
one of the following grounds misconduct
fraud or irregularity by any primary or
election official or official sufficient
to change or place and doubt the result
there's no evidence that any of that
happened here yet again as you pointed
out it's almost like none of the facts
matter this is all about 20/20 this is
all about building the momentum for more
identity politics going into 2020 with
the goal of finally flipping Georgia to
a total blue state they want to do that
in Florida Newt they want to do it in
Texas and they've made some gains in
Texas and the suburbs around Dallas they
won Pete's session seat so this is this
is a play that they're making across the
country even in the reddest of states
like Texas sure I mean let's start with
the idea why would we think they want to
obey the law they don't think the law
matters they think the law represents
the old order and stacey abrams said at
one point in the campaign her Brewer
wave includes legal and illegal people
now then she said oh I didn't really
mean that but she does mean it and again
over and over everywhere you turn
California which is had a weird series
of votes Arizona
the fact is again and again you have a
democratic party dedicated to winning at
any cost
dedicating to steal the election if they
have to and if they can win dedicated to
blaming the Republican see this weird
experience they try to steal the
election
if they fail they say you're stealing it
because you want honestly and sadly
because of the liberal news media they
get away with a lot of this well we have
other very bizarre things happening and
now I can't believe already looking at
2020 but a woman that you have put out
front and sunny air center is someone
who you think might be the nominee in
2020 is Kamala Harris and yesterday I
think she shocked even Democrats with
how she described ice okay so you made
this let's first play newts prediction
the last time you were on about the
senator we're speaking about I
personally think it's gonna be Kamala
Harris I'm going to stick with that
unless she doesn't run I think an
african-american woman former attorney
general from California law which has
enormous resources and I think she
clears the field like I said you
predicted that she was gonna be the
20/20 nominee now alluding to what I
just referenced this is what she said
about immigrations customs enforcement
just yesterday are you aware of the
perception of many about what how the
the the power and the discretion that
ice is being used to enforce the laws
and do you see any parallels I do not
see any parallels between I'm talking
about prisoners and agents I'm talking
about perception I do not see a parallel
between what is constitutionally
mandated as it relates to enforcing the
law are you aware that there's the
perceptions we know are you aware that
there's a ice in the same category as
the KKK yeah the KKK knew that's that's
where we are now with a duly appointed
agency under the umbrella of homeland
security that's what it is it's all
about race but in a democratic prime
weight in a democratic primary would you
rather be the person who is condemning
law enforcement or the person who's
defending law enforcement the only the
person who's defending sanctuary cities
which are an explicit act of breaking
the law
or the only person who says maybe we
shouldn't break the law and should turn
in illegal criminals now you know in a
Democratic primary it is a dead loser to
be pro-ice and to be pro locking up
criminals I me this sounds weird but I'm
not sure it's weird for them yeah so for
them it makes it makes perfect sense I
want to play what I want to play one
more thing for you this is from your
friend Joe Scarborough former Republican
a Panhandle native what what he said
about what's happening to the Republican
Party in the former stronghold for
instance of Orange County in California
let's watch you look at it Orange County
my gosh is Tom nickel said
congratulations Republicans
you just lost Reagan County it looks
like it's going to be a complete wipeout
I remember when Loretta Sanchez beat b1
Bob Dornan in Orange County back in the
1990's it was a stunner an absolute
shock now mica it is AC of a huge huge
crushing defeat for Trump republicanism
is that what was defeated in California
trump republicanism knew it's a very
facile analysis by the the towering
intellect over at MSNBC no look I think
we have to face the reality that in the
largest state in the country California
and the fourth largest state in the
country New York the size of the Union
based machines are now so enormous that
we don't frankly know right now how to
compete with them I mean that's how big
this problem is and so I think we've got
to confront the reality that we are
dealing with a very profound change we
just had a candidate for City Council in
Seattle and independent withdraw from
the race because his wife was being
threatened her job was being threatened
her safety was being threatened and he
wrote a very poignant memo to all of his
supporters and I was an email saying
that he was frightened to even run in
Seattle
because the forces of the left now are
so vicious and so hostile and we have a
real problem in our largest state
California in our fourth largest state
New York in that both now our centers of
enormous Union based power that is so
brutal and has so much money that we
frankly right now don't know how to
compete with them well I think look
there's mass immigration has changed
California no doubt about it and in many
races there's no Republican running at
all they're just basically two Democrats
running and running against each other
and I don't I don't I don't think this
has been happening over years it didn't
it just didn't just start happening with
Trump that's the part of the facile
analysis this has been a process over
two decades at least in California